White House Press Secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders
holds a lot of press briefings.
But I, for one, don't think they
are asking all the questions
we need answers to.
So we decided to hold
another one
right here right now.
That's right.
Sarah Huckabee Sanders
and the "Late Night" Press Corps
are here in our studio
and ready to go.
So without further ado,
it's time for the "Late Night"
White House Press Briefing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Sarah, Sarah, yes, over here.
Sarah.
Sarah, Sarah, over here, yes,
thank you.
Seth Meyers,
"Late Night with Seth Meyers."
Secretary Sanders,
when are you going
to start telling us the truth?
-Um, not today or tomorrow
or at any point ever.
[ Laughter ]
-Great.
Can you tell us a little bit
about Eric Trump's
birthday party?
-No one from the White House
staff will attend.
[ Laughter ]
-What did Jared Kushner
say to Donald Trump
during the election?
-I wish I could vote for you,
but I'm only 11.
[ Laughter ]
-Sarah, where do you see
yourself in five years?
-Further from the truth.
[ Audience "ohhs", laughter ]
-President Trump
seems to be fairly unfriendly
to Angela Merkel.
Was there ever a time
when Trump liked Germany?
-From 1942 to 1945.
[ Audience groans,
scattered applause ]
[ Audience booing,
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Why does President Trump want
to meet with Vladimir Putin?
-To accept the check.
[ Laughter ]
-What did President Trump tell
his kids to do on Mother's Day?
-Call your moms.
[ Audience groans, laughter ]
-The President has announced
a new branch
of the military called
the Space Force.
What's the first step
in getting that set up?
-We're gonna meet with
President Moon next week.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What does President Trump call
one jumping jack?
-The White House
Sports and Fitness Day.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Sarah, be honest, do you ever
feel like you're
a little passive aggressive?
-I would be happy to answer it
if you would stop talking
long enough to let me do that.
[ Audience groaning,
scattered laughter ]
-That was bad.
[ Laughter ]
-What is the line,
"My hump, my hump, my hump,
my lovely lady lumps" from?
-That is actually repeated
a number of times
throughout the Bible.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, right.
Take as much time as you need.
You can answer
as long as you have to.
Can you describe The President's
health regimen?
-Cake.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
So just cake?
What should I think about
when I'm trying to last longer
in the bedroom?
-Rudy Giuliani's love life.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah, that'll work.
What is the best way
to win at table tennis?
-Making sure that we no longer
allow China to play.
-Yeah.
[ Audience groans, laughter ]
What did The President
say to his genitals
before meeting
with Stormy Daniels?
-Happy birthday, Richard.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, you know what, uh,
your turn.
Why don't you tell a joke?
-I work every single day
to give you accurate
and up to date information.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's fantastic.
That's a good one, Sarah. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, looks like
we are out of time.
So, on behalf of the rest
of the press corps,
have a good night.
We'll be right back with
Benicio del Toro, everybody.